[Applause]
[Music]
it's driving me crazy not a long drive
those are my grandma's napkin rings
wow
stupid gorgeous you're flirting with me
you're irresistible man I'm saying it's
a lot of work for a mediocre piece of
meat that's all I gotta say
s we'll be right back I'm gonna go check
on seal in the room
[Music]
with this
hold on I do have to do everything hey
okay go help yourself to drinks at the
bar by the way the table looks beautiful
seeing this is new oh peg oh I love
these
stop it you got this shot I need a copy
like right away
anybody leaving a stretcher yet wow did
you see Grandma's napkin rings on the
table you look amazing you see Stewie
yeah
do not drown each other and
end up dead you can have a problem with
me
here
Bob purple
that's safe okay hey
wait for Jenny to come out to help you
Denny Peggy this is Summer House tell me
about it it ought to be I told you it
was a Showplace
hey now
[Music]
blue Pig
let's go let's go
[Music]
I asked you to spring for a stash
outside
my kid is visiting you ruined the
holiday did he not me it's the plumbing
[Music]
hey Happy Thanksgiving by the way never
again